welcome to the House of Lords to let
committee on AI in weapon systems our
evidence today focuses on questions of
accountability capability and
transparency and I'm very glad to
welcome our Witnesses into this public
session in the room we have Professor
Dean Murphy Calder from the University
of Glasgow which we've already heard
quite a lot about in this uh in our work
and in the room room remotely we have
Professor gopal remchern from the
University of Southampton
and from the Netherlands Organization
for Applied scientific research we're
delighted to welcome or be remotely Dr
durian van diggerland thank you very
much for being with us today may I
remind you as I remind all of us that
the Ascension is being broadcast and
will be transcribed
my name is Christopher the Lord
spiritual and a member of the select
committee and I'm standing in today for
our distinguished uh chair
um Lord Liz vane who very much regrets
that he's not able to be with us today
following uh Lord chairs example may I
begin with with the first question which
is
um which is a big question
[Applause]
um and uh concerns the the area that
we've been grappling with all along uh
which is um agency I suppose in general
and and what is meant by uh meaningful
human control of machines
um I I have a a sort of sharper version
of of that question which is along the
lines of we're conscious that there's
evidence that over time people can
become over-reliant on machine generated
recommendations
um and I must admit when I'm in my car
and I got the sat nav on uh I sometimes
find myself over relying upon it and
thinking I'm not quite sure that's right
but I'll do it anyway or sometimes even
the opposite no you're always wrong I'll
do my own thing and that's not helpful
either I just wonder how we wonder how
big a concern that is in in AI web
systems and what might be done about it
that sort of uh bias to believe as it
were
um but this is such a broad topic and
we'll need to keep relatively focused
but uh Professor Calder I think you you
wanted to to address that general
question of human meaningful human
control but by giving us a little bit of
background that may help us conceptually
thank you all right thank you very much
yes I think to answer this question I
wanted to say a few words about what
kind of machines or systems we're
talking about here so to my mind these
are called cyber physical systems
and what they consist of is physical
devices called sensors and actuators
that are in the physical world so they
sense data and they affect actions
in the software world there's a notion
of control that does some notion of
situation awareness what situation is
happening and decision making and those
decisions will affect the sensors
perhaps where they are how often they're
communicated with and actually control
the actuators
um and humans may be involved in that
decision making so we have a range from
purely automated to degrees of autonomy
and two standard phrases or definitions
that are used are human in the loop
where the human has the ability to stop
or start these actions or human and on
the loop where the human has oversight
of the whole system but not explicit
events in either case there are serious
issues which we will come on to later
about human involvement boredom
challenge of involved in this decision
making
but just to complete the picture of the
Cyber physical system a third component
is a networking Communications so
Communications within the system and
from the outside world to to control the
system
and I mentioned that because there may
be issues that we may lose that
communication there may be issues of
timing and lag there may be issues of
bandwidth and power particularly if this
system is remote
and finally just to draw your attention
to their probabilistic components
throughout these systems there's lots of
uncertainty for example just even with
sensing
sensors can degrade they can be up
upgraded they can fail they can turn
right lie and when we're dealing with
rare events it can be very difficult to
distinguish between an error and
something really unusual has just
happened so that's the context of those
machines and that raises two questions
in my mind the first is what's special
about a weapon system as a cyber
physical system and the second is what's
special about AI as a probabilistic
component by the way don't worry my
other colleagues you you'll come in I'll
leave you more time to answer questions
in a minute just going back to what's
special about a weapon system as a CPS
well every cyber physical system is
designed for purpose and will operate in
a legal framework in this case we have
potentially destruction and harm to
humans maybe offensive maybe defensive
what's special about it is decisions may
have to be made very quickly and there
may be problems with um with the timing
and timeline to my mind the key
actuation the key act would be weapons
firing but that's for others to
determine
and the second question is what's
special about the AI component as a
probabilistic component well there's a
couple of things as soon as you have
probability a probabilistic behavior in
a system it becomes very hard to test
and reason about it an AI component
makes that even more interesting because
the AI component itself needs to be
tested and we're going to be talking
about that and the role of data is
really really important and so it's also
then can be very tricky to monitor the
behavior of that AI component within
that bigger broader Software System
questions for me are where's the human
agency in the system and also where is
the AI in the system if the AI component
is controlling air conditioning is that
such a concern
if it's controlling weapons firing I
imagine it's more of a concern so I
wanted to I don't want me to be flippant
but it's just to put it in context you
have to think about where is the AI
component in that whole system
thank you very much I wonder whether um
either uh well both of our other two uh
Witnesses
um might want to uh either add to that
General comment or uh or also we ought
to begin to focus on the the specific
question of whether there is
um a bias uh to believe uh and Trust the
the system
um built into the sort of uh uh the
human between Dynamic
um uh I think gopal has things to say
yeah
thank you yeah thank you for the
opportunity to to be here today um so uh
for me there are three elements to the
issue of meaningful human control uh one
is reaction time
um a second one is complacency and
um the the third one is
um the notion of uh learning from
experience and
um and and whether
um humans or humans are already Guided
by machines without realizing this
so in terms of reaction time I think
it's irresponsible
to put people in situations where they
have to make decisions along machines
alongside machines that are making
decisions at you know sub second level
right so they they have to work at
machine speed and that's responsible to
people in in those situations and and
it's then difficult to ask for
Meaningful human control in that
situation
the second thing is around complacency
if we have for example experience work
driving a car with some automated tools
over long periods of time we tend to
become over reliant on these on the
systems and this is particularly the
case for pilots who are flying drones
for example
um uh out there and uh and then get
tired and then to rely on the machine to
make decisions in low risk situations
and suddenly a higher risk situation
arises and they're not prepared for it
so they may become complacent about what
what's what's happening in the world
and uh and then asking for Meaningful
human control doesn't really account for
the fact that humans do get tired humans
do tend to become
um over reliant on Automation and the
third thing is as you will know every
day you get
offered suggestions on on your
e-commerce favorite e-commerce platform
or your movie streaming platform and
these machines are are shaping your
preferences for various products and
services
and there's a real question here as to
whether we are in control of our choices
whether these ai-based systems already
shape our our decisions and and I think
that's where all these these three
dimensions of meaningful human control
for me was the issue of of a responsible
um uh design are we really thinking
um about the whole holistic holistic way
about systems of humans and machines and
and how they form Partnerships that
where humans and machines really
um influence each other's decisions
um sometimes in situations where one
needs to be
can react faster than the other and
these pose real problems for us
um of our lawyers for our military
commanders and and for civil society
thank you very much
um Professor Ram chin um Professor Dr
diglin I wonder whether you want to come
in and could I turn another dimension in
the time Dimension uh we're very
conscious of the speed at which um uh
all of this is is operating and also the
adaptability
of these weapon systems to changing
circumstances how do we retain uh any
sort of meaningful human control at
speed
yes so there's there is a that is an
important problem for a meaningful human
control especially in the military and I
believe that real-time control is is one
way of establishing control where the
human steps in and at real time makes
decisions that are executed by the
machine but we can also shift that
moment of control earlier in time for
example in the planning phase and that
is something which we call prior control
so the humans specifies a contract with
the machine and thinks out all the
possible events that could happen and
also specifies directives that the
machine must follows in case that
happens and then the machine goes off
autonomously and when these situations
arise it will act according to the
instructions that are given by the human
earlier and that is a form of control
which is relatively new in a human gene
interaction
but it's actually quite common in human
interaction when human teams interact
with each other they do that all the
time and you should also realize that
these kinds of behaviors they and
anti-interactions they will develop over
time
um
what is really important then of course
is that the human at the moment that
these instructions are given can
anticipate on how the scenario will
unfold but you must also be aware of how
the how the robot would act in those
circumstances and which directions
directives to give in
that way you can shift the moment of
control to a moment where there's where
there's more time
um another note I would like to make on
the on the Reliance issue indeed the the
over-reliance is an issue but we can
design for that so we can make sure that
in the interaction the machine
communicates to the human when the
machine is uncertain and that the
machine sometimes maybe sees Noble
situations which it has not encountered
before in the training set and if we add
that to the human machine interaction
the human and the Machine also gradually
over time will develop a calibrated
trust and they know what a machine can
do and what it can do and when to step
in
is very very helpful indeed thank you um
Lord Hamilton I think you wanted to come
in would very much like to come in
um it strikes me that there's a
contradiction in terms here because
we're talking about human control and
we're talking about autonomous weapon
systems surely by the nature of an
autonomous weapon system there is no
human control should we not be actually
talking about responsibility for the
whole system probably in the hands of
some military commander who would then
pull the hill system if it wasn't
operating properly
yeah perhaps I'd comment usually when we
say autonomous system we think about
degrees of autonomy so there's a
spectrum from as I said fully automated
to you might have some actions some
functions are automated sets of
functions to the complete system being
automated so when I hear the word
autonomous I don't assume it is fully
autonomous
and that's a really key point in these
systems to what degree do we have full
autonomy and this occurs in many
paradigms from driverless cars to
medical devices Prosthetics water
networks Etc
thank you very much
um May I bring in lord lord Brown at
this point and um uh Dr Dylan and
professor ramji and perhaps you could
hold in in mind also Lord Hamilton's
question as we come on to this one thank
you Lord Brown thank you very much so
actually I mean I I think that Dr Van
Dylan's um reference to how you can
in anticipation of these events where
you may need to change the behavior of
the machine you can program it to do
this in advance all right so this is
exactly the space that I want to dig
into which is
which is I mean we're dealing here with
machines which technically
you know do not always uh the algorithms
instruct them don't always operate in a
deterministic fashion we're told
regularly but despite being told that
you know an algorithm can behave
markedly differently in what we perceive
to be identical sets of circumstances at
different times
um
there seems to be to to it causes me
personally and I think it will cause the
committee a great deal of difficulty as
to what recommendations we make
if we're dealing with non-deterministic
machines
I mean how do we set thresholds for Its
Behavior you know how do we put it you
know into a mindset I mean I kind of
know how you do this with children as
they grow up you know because of
experience but I was never very
successful but so I just I just wonder
you know is this possible with this type
of technology I don't think we know
enough about this technology and how the
technology behaves
and how it works as to whether we can
apply these sort of human controls to it
you know I mean my my sense is that when
people talk to me about these machines
these machines will do what is in their
best interests not necessarily in our
best interests so can we with confidence
you know train the machine in the same
way as we can train a soldier to act
instinctively in a particular way when
he or it is in this set of circumstances
honestly the evidence we have suggested
me that we probably won't be able to do
that Professor Ram Tim what do you think
yeah
um these are really good points and
um I think the research shows that there
are different degrees of autonomy or or
as we would like to call it flexible
autonomy levels that would apply in
different situations as you rightly say
these systems are probabilistic so they
may not even correctly recognize the
situation they are in to choose the
right course of action
um or even if they recognize the right
the right situation then they might
choose a random course of action that is
unexpected so in those situations these
what matters really is the level of risk
that your incur if it's a low risk
situation you might be okay with a
machine
being automated and and maybe some make
some mistakes
um that that will not have a huge impact
but in high stake high risk situations
you may want to have more control and
that's where we came about maybe five or
nine different levels of autonomy where
either you ask or the machine you you
you code the machine to ask for
permission to take action or you code
the machine to
um act uh and then tell you what has
happened or you ask the machine to
completely to do everything without
telling you
um depending on on the level of risk
that it it perceives but then the level
of risk is something that a human may be
better able to judge or could be trained
into the machine so you could learn this
over multiple experiences but I think
the challenge arises when You Face an
unseen situation previously unseen
situation and and that's where I think
it is important then to ensure that
whoever is making decisions is
um is is account for it and that means
Trucking where data is coming from where
decisions are being made either by the
human or by the machine or jointly
thank you very much I knew the challenge
today would be to move on from uh from
from question one we could spend our
whole time on it um we do have three I
think um bids for uh for supplementaries
on this so would you allow me to take
those together so we can sort of get
them on the table and then I'll invite
brief responses to those so um uh and
baroness Hodgson if we could have yours
on there thank you I'll try and be quick
because I I know it's a lot
um we were talking you were talking
mentioning about kind of Pride control
and pre-planning and I absolutely
understand about that and often you may
plan it plan something and then tell it
it's the you know when that's happened
you may want to then have further
decision making in the planning that
what worries me particularly is I see
how efficient a machine can be for
systematic decision making but there is
a lack of empathy and you know I don't
see how you would ever
put in empathy into its into its
decision making and that causes me great
worry because I think in in in in
matters of conflict
there would be some form of empathy
would come into the human decision
making and I don't see how this is
included in machine decision making
thank you bonus Hodgson and if we could
come on to you Lord and then um Lord
kriezmann a new member of the committee
if if I may invite you just to put your
question on this and then we'll see what
the responses are thank you Lord very
cool I think it's a a pretty short
question it's just to try and
um get in our minds I think what is
distinctive in my mind anyway what is
distinctive about the weapon system that
includes
um AI or um uh or or indeed of fully
autonomous weapon system if if we're
talking about basically whether it works
it seems to me that a lot of this
discussion is does it do what it's
intended to do can it be relied on to
work in all circumstances or not now
that to me seems no different from it's
different in degree maybe but it's not
different as a principle from any other
kind of weapon I mean um I don't know
does a does a machine gun work better in
certain temperatures than others or is
it disabled because of uh I don't know
whatever Factor you can imagine but it's
helpful in our thinking at least in my
thinking if I know that the problem
we're wrestling with here is not
actually a brand new unthought of
problem when it comes to whether the
weapon works or not which seems to be a
very crucial part of the agonizing that
we're doing about um about Ai and AWS
thanks very much and then to bring in
Lord friezmann
thank you Lord chairman I I I don't have
any interest to declare let me start
because I know I've got to start with
that and this isn't supposed to be a
dystopian kind of question at all I've
been trying to draw on I'm a
mathematician by training I've been
trying to draw on past experiences
running a trading floor in a large
Investment Bank one of the uh one of the
things that I observed was that many of
the uh Traders many of them are good
deal younger than me and almost all of
them mathematicians when they were
trading in derivatives uh
claim to know about the the
mathematical bases of the operations
they were doing although it seemed to me
to be very unclear that they did they
didn't seem to have a kind of an instant
depth understanding of the algorithms
but nonetheless when they were presented
with various sorts of information they
gravitated very rapidly to particular
Solutions
and they were doing it in a very fast
time frame and this is nothing like as
advanced as the AI and weapon systems
that we're talking about my question
Lord chairman is this is there to any
extent
um not just a matter of meaningful human
control but do the way in ways in which
the machines work train the humans to
respond in particular ways rather like
some of the descriptions that we've just
heard about using our SAT navs when
they're obviously telling us ridiculous
things but uh but but people begin
beginning to behave almost automatically
in not just the questions they ask but
the instructions they give because that
is the way they've been guided to and is
there a risk in that
thank you very much so we have a clutch
of questions there on the back of the
determinism there's empathy there's
distinctiveness and there's a sort of
reverse training
um but may I ask you to be really
disciplined in your in your answers you
won't be able to address them all but if
we start with you Lord diggling and then
we'll we need to move on to question two
pretty shortly thank you
yes thank you so there's there's a lot a
lot to end up I'm back here
um with respect to the empathy question
I I think that that really uh hits the
the main point so the question is how
much power are we willing to hand over
to the machine and there is a draw a
line to be drawn there and for
people interested in this great and
meaningful human control the line is
that the machine should not be capable
of making moral decisions well what does
it mean to make a moral decision that is
making a decision by the machine itself
which has not been pre-planned by the
Human by The Machine itself that affects
human values and that have might have
legal consequences
um those uh decisions should be left to
the human because uh indeed the machine
does not have empathy and it does not
have Consciousness and we are
uncomfortable when the machine makes
these decisions by itself
so we should make sure that uh the human
in these cases uh uses this uh Fire
Control well what is the difference then
between an AI systems and uh traditional
systems is that the traditional systems
are more uh acting in very deterministic
ways and also in predictable
environments and the Machine can also
cope with unforeseen question
circumstances so interpret the situation
and come up with the solution itself
well then we should be very careful
distinct to distinguish between those
decisions that the machine can perform
autonomously and those
decisions that are morally Laden and
which uh made by the by the human either
real time or um or prior
so then the last issue also uh which
came up is the relation between human
and machine and I think the proper
metaphor should be as a team partner so
the human and the Machine should
collaborate together and the Machine
should also be aware that it should
involve the human in in certain
circumstances and you should also
develop your team over time and the
humans should also all of these things
that will develop is that the machine
knows when to involve the human uh and
when not
thank you very much impressively
succinct a professor anything you would
like to add three quick points I think
first of all the big question is why
automate at all
and typically I think we automate when
we've got a repetition or an unsafe
environment we want to work those are
reasons why we want to automate tasks so
I think we need to think about that in
this context why are we automating the
second is whenever we're talking about
AI components it all depends on how the
component was trained and how the
training data relates to the testing
data which relates to the data it's
going to meet in real life it's
extremely important to consider the
alignment of those that's really going
to affect the overall behavior of that
component and I would keep coming back
to that question of where is the AI
component in the system
and and the last is maybe to to say a
phrase what we call as understandable AI
where the outputs of any AI system we
want them to be contextualized to
support human agency so it's back to
this so we're all three of us we're
talking about the same thing it's it's
called human autonomy teaming how do we
work together with the machine and do we
just find those boundaries thank you
very much I think we're learning a lot
Professor ramcham anything you'd like to
add on this very briefly very quickly
um on the notion of feedback loops um
where you know machines are guiding
humans
um by the decisions that they make or
the information they provide I think
there's
[Music]
very quickly I was talking about
feedback loops how machines are now
guiding humans based on the data that
they've used to be to train and and and
to classify images for example we're at
risk of of letting humans be guided in
in ways that are um are not suitable in
certain situations and on the notion of
empathy and whether machines work or not
I think that for me the the key point is
who is responsible for
um failures of the system when the
machine has done something an acceptable
um or unlawful who is who is actually
responsible and and we are struggling a
bit with that question but it is not a
matter just for
um for this group or for assists or
philosophers to decide on I think it's a
better for civil society to decide on
because at the end of the day these
autonomous weapons will be used against
um enemies that are looking to to
um to win the war right so we should not
we should we should be mindful of those
situations where which are high stakes
and are likely to affect us in ways that
are unpredictable thank you very much
I'm going to move on to another question
now which some follows on from Lord
grayco's question about well well does
it work uh Lord Hamilton yes what
methods are available to ensure that AI
systems will perform robustly in
settings which might be different from
those in which they've been trained and
to train I would also to the original
requirement what testing systems will be
needed to evaluate the performance of AI
systems and I'd like to add to that does
do our Witnesses agree that in all
probability we will only come to a
conclusion whether these systems are
working as intended by going to war
physical there
oh boy
um question so to my mind there's two
aspects to testing here there's testing
of the AI component which is a fairly
well-defined contact concept of after we
have trained a model we then test it
where we have Notions of ground truth so
we can understand how it actually
performs and then we actually deploy it
on on the real data
but then that component is part of a
bigger system which may be a totally
deterministic software framework and we
have to test that so it's it's coming
together of two disciplines which called
software engineering and shall we say
data science so it's about testing in
those two different contexts
um thank you I don't want to ask the
other witnesses to to repeat what's been
said but do you have anything uh further
to uh to add professor remton
yes I I think there's there's the
element of of systems testing and and
verification that is already in place
but with the research we're doing in the
ukri trust where the autonomous systems
program what we're finding is that these
these testing Frameworks are not
suitable for AI systems that work
alongside humans
the humans tend to cause most problems
in in some cases as we saw with the
watchkeeper program where most drones
that were built as part of this program
crashed because of human error and
that's because the design the testing
the verification framework cannot
account for human behaviors human and
predictability
um and this is this is the key research
challenge we're trying to address right
now thank you Dr Dylan
yes so um I I think this is a this is an
interesting uh a point because a machine
learning model can only make predictions
based on the patterns it has seen in the
training data and it cannot generate
entirely new new knowledge when it's
when it hasn't seen anything before so
we should during development make sure
that we have a diverse training set and
really try to anticipate in which kind
of situations this system will be used
and that are examples from that
situations will be in the training set
and also during testing we can use
techniques like web teaming that some
people outside the development team try
to come up with examples that could
occur in practice but which the
developers did not uh think of and and
include in your training set
thank you little Ben did you want to
come can I come back yes because I don't
think my questions really been answered
when it comes to Conventional Weapons
when we go to war we discover that some
Conventional Weapons fail in terms of
what we expected of them and some exceed
what we expected of them so surely you
have to test these systems in war to
know what they're really capable of and
whether they are as errant as some
people believe they might be
any responses to that
I think I would say that in general for
any system we deploy until we deploy it
in what we call the wild in the real
world we just don't know we can test we
can reason and we can analyze but the
proof
ing as they say in the eating it is in
the actual deployment whatever the
purpose I would keep going back to the
purpose of the system the rule intended
for the system
yes if I can add to that uh the problem
in Warfare is that the enemy will try to
be unpredictable so they will try to act
in a way that uh the system has not been
trained upon
can I jump in please
um I think what we're getting at here
though the question is really about
military Advantage does it actually give
you any kind of military Advantage does
it it may be working perfectly but if
you're spending a lot of time
trying to fix its issues trying to get
an understanding of why it is making a
decision just so that you're accountable
for what you're doing you're wasting
time and that could put you at risk
there are a number of of military
personnel that have been shut down
because they were looking too much of
their drawn mission control systems on
their on their tablets for example so
testing these these systems in the wild
otherwise is definitely essential before
you think uh you know they actually
confer any kind of military Advantage
thank you Lord Brown yeah I mean I mean
I think this
I mean this Carries On from the question
I asked earlier I mean there is
something in very significant and the
the the last sentence of Lord Hamilton's
question which is I mean conflict is
chaos
environments conflicted environments are
chaotic
um and and we seek to train human beings
to operate instinctively in those
environments so that they are not
distracted from their job by what's
going on around about them and they and
we train them to relate to each other
you know which is why we celebrate you
know the fact that people will go to war
not for their country or not for their
King but for their mates right so
um they will behave in a particular way
so these are chaotic environments in
which we anticipate the things will
change and the enemy gets a vote
they you know they are constantly trying
to disturb those environments and in
relation to electronic equipment they're
constantly trying to beat our security
and interfere with it right so so like
like I mean like the question I asked
earlier I mean this is not what we need
to be told because we know this right
what we need to be told is are these
machines capable of being hardened to
operate in the way in which we want them
to or predict that they will in that set
of circumstances when they're that are
built into them these inherently
unpredictable behaviors
I mean is Is it wise to put these
machines into these environments when we
don't know
where wherein in the cool of a
laboratory they will guarantee to behave
the same way twice
thank you
who would like to come in on this
critical question
go ahead yeah so so so my thoughts are
that uh it's a very complex and
interrelated complex environment but we
could try to identify
well-defined context Within These tasks
and test our systems for this tasks and
then we can reliable reliably deploy
them and the system of the uh the
behavior of the AI should not be very
unpredictable to the human if if that is
the case then we shouldn't use it
do you agree Professor called yeah
absolutely and it it I'll keep going
back to my points where is the AI in
that overall system but I would maybe
also stress we should pick apart perhaps
the offensive and the defensive role for
these these systems perhaps we have
different
overall agreements about what we want
when we're talking about a defensive
weapon rather than an offensive weapon
because as pointed out you know the the
enemy at per se is also trying to
confuse us
another question from Lord Fairfax on
this same theme though uh well thank you
I I I hope it's not too general question
it's about the Advent of quantum
computing
um do you see that any relevance of
quantum Computing to these questions or
is that a red herring and this is a
question for all of you
my quick answer is red herring
I will point out there are other aspects
of quantum Technologies like Quantum
Imaging Quantum sensing they might
increase our abilities to for example
sense and actuate in terms of those
systems that could make a bigger
difference I think than Quantum
computation per se thank you professor
a red red herring for the moment but I
think longer term you look we will look
at building machine learning systems
that uh work at the quantum level and
therefore will bring in new capabilities
um when it comes to autonomous weapon
systems so so not for now
thank you well I think we should move on
if we if we could to to question four
um and um
Lord Cyprus I think you're going to come
in on this we've already Yes on this
question of of uh potential damage to
data but uh over to you
yes so I was just wondering what
mechanisms can be put into place to try
and reduce the risk of sort of
adversaries trying to tamper with
training data right from the outside are
there are there ways to mitigate or
prevent this
whoever wishes to go first
thank you
um Dr diggleman
yeah so um I think you should uh the
selection of the training data should be
done by the development team and you
should not just uh let you let your AI
go out in a while collect any training
data it encounters and the development
team they should carefully see if the
data has not been tampered with
um
so no online learning
um but the enemy can can tamper with
reality and that way create a mismatch
between what what the system has learned
and what it sees in in reality and that
is a real risk the the enemy you can do
will try to be unpredictable and and
camouflage their systems in a strange
way that uh that that the AI will not
recognize it
professor emptin yeah okay so so the
real risk here is where we've we've got
um a machine Learning System that is
for which the lead training data has
been tampered with would then result in
this machine and this system
misclassifying certain things for
example a child holding a toy gun could
be mistaken by the system to be a
terrorist
I think that's that's that's the that's
kind of potential risk that you have
with with a tampered training data and
data is at the core of most machine
Learning Systems specifically
the way to solve these issues for
example is to to try and assure that
data pipeline protecting that data
pattern and that was what the project
Maven was trying to do in in the US a
few years back so securing the data
pipeline but securing the data centers
on which this data sets are stored but
as as my colleague just talked about in
terms of fooling these systems there is
a risk that if you're using a black box
machine Learning System that you don't
understand how it works you don't
understand how it's learned from this
training data it could be it could be
subject to certain kinds of attacks so
you could use some of the features that
it has learned from this training data
even though it's it's unadulterated data
it could someone could use certain
features of that data set to fool the
system and we've seen lots of examples
of this in the literature so there's a
risk with black box Opera machine
Learning Systems in particular physical
the
would you be able to come in on that
last question that last point is there
anything more you'd like to add on that
on the on the Black Bolt style I think
you've said it very well this is a
classic problem of AI is about that
training data and in a sense the more
you try and open up the black box and
review and try to summarize what it does
you've kind of given away the game to
the adversary who can then go and poison
the data and this if you have controlled
all the the data yourself that's fine
but it's I think that's becoming
increasingly difficult and unrealistic
and that we are having off-the-shelf
components here or we are going to you
know open source out on on the web Etc
so it's very hard to control those data
sources
Hudson on the same thing I
think into thinking about the security
of the systems in general that I mean I
suppose the kind of whole sci-fi concept
that something somebody tampers with the
machine and turns it back on uh to
become a you know on on the people that
are trying to use it
I mean how could one prevent other
people accessing these systems
can I say so there's there's technical
answers here but this is also part of a
bigger question of unintended uses of
Technology who thought you know any a
jet would become a bomb
Etc we can turn any system and use it in
ways that it weren't intended here I'm
not talking about the cyber security but
the system of getting into the machine
and into the network is a different
issue here from trying to tamper with
the data that's used in the in the
training steps we would expect in these
systems that you would be retraining
them at regular intervals
that's a big question is how often are
they retrained
thank you very much I'd like to move on
if we made to uh to the next question
um uh and uh may I bring in Lord Clement
Jones on this uh question really
important one about uh principles into
operational uh detail thank you chair
and it's a bit of a change of subject
here uh given that we've been talking
about in a sense the nature of the the
weapons it's how can the mod translate
high-level principles like reliability
and responsibility to operational
reality what procedures are needed to
ensure AI enabled weapon systems will be
responsibly designed and lawfully used
it's really all about compliance
um and of course what I'm thinking of is
the mod policy statement ambitious safe
responsible and they're setting out of
the various principles that they think
should be applied human centricity
responsibility understanding bias and
harm litigation
I mean as well as the
um the question about compliance
mechanisms
um I mean you might also comment on the
realism of trying to have these uh
ethical principles as well can we start
with Professor Calder
thanks I think every organization that
develops software has to face these
issues they already face them even
without AI what are the processes of
developing software how do they test how
do they verify how are they open about
the methods they use it becomes even
more acute in this context and I think a
lot of it simply comes down to culture
in the organization how are how
professional are the people involved in
developing the software What's the
culture about the transparency of the
development the deployment the
discussion of fairness the ability to
challenge I don't mean challenge within
the system the the Software System
they're building but challenge within
the whole software process
I'll come to uh professor ramton in a
minute but
um so what's your view about the realism
of embedding that culture in a a
Ministry a department devoted to defense
or indeed an armed service itself
I suppose I don't think I'm able comment
on the cultural aspects of that
particular department but I think it
comes back to the
professional developed software
developers how are they being educated
and and the culture in which they are
working together and I think anyone
would say it's not just about the
software development but we need other
Specialists within those teams as well
and it's always again about diversity of
those teams ability to challenge each
other
thank you professor ramchan
yeah I'd like to comment on the on the
notion of adding sort of new
um principles or ways of working to
um to the development of these of these
systems
um and I think the worry there is is
these principles May interfere with
what's already in place in a way that
undermines that military advantage that
they might have so these principles have
to be implemented in a way that
supports those teams on the ground and I
think working with the teams on the
ground who who can actually build these
systems very quickly as we've seen in
Ukraine
many machine learning systems or drone
based systems were built by
um by personal underground within two
weeks and deployed with with quite a bit
of success so one thing is to make sure
that these principles implemented in an
additive way to what's already in place
and and that needs um collaboration with
people on the ground it has to be fair
to those systems
um who are
um hit it has to be fair to the humans
involved in these systems and I think
that's where the notion of
accountability
um is is I think is the foundational
element of of all these ai-based systems
to to to get Assurance or to give
Comfort to the humans in that
organization that when they make a
decision it will be it will be some it
someone will be able to prove that they
have they are responsible for it or some
or a machine has has decided on their
behalf
um within certain uh regulatory or legal
boundaries so the number of of
um sort of ground up and and top-down
approaches to I think implementing those
principles that need to take into
account the reality of of the situation
that that people face at wall yes I mean
does that
you've explained the the issues I mean
how realistic is it do you think I mean
we've talked about the culture and so on
how realistic do you think it is to
embed those in in an organization
in many circumstances
I think I think that's where we need to
involve not just engineers and and and
scientists in in building these systems
and implementing these principles I
think involving people from different
disciplinary backgrounds
um you know whether it's a social
scientists psychologists and others who
will help make sure that these systems
are adhere to these principles in ways
that are fair to humans and and and uh
okay stakeholders
thank you uh Dr Van diggling
yeah so I think uh what is also
important that a principle like
meaningful human control uh is not
necessarily in conflict with military
Effectiveness I think uh the military
will want to keep control over their AI
based systems but we should show them
how to do that and for that you need
these requirements to be much more
precise and really spell out how they
translate to training requirements over
the entire life cycle of the system how
you should develop your user interfaces
and monitor over time
Etc
um
because it will be difficult to do
software Audits and it will also be very
difficult to prove that the enemy has
used their AI based systems in a fully
autonomous mode unlike chemical weapons
there will be no spill of of chemicals
or signs that that they have been used
autonomously
yes so I mean you talk about the
training but then
um how you how do you make sure that
that you're once everybody's trained
that actually the principles are being
put into into effect
doctors yes so that that is that is uh I
I agree with with the with the previous
witness uh that is also a part of
culture I mean we did that in Safety
Research where we understand that the
whole safety culture of an organization
and logging incidents and everybody
being aware of these problems and and
trying to improve it is important uh to
uh to to have Safe Systems uh and the
same holds for a responsible AI
thank you thank you I know that um Lord
procont would like to come in on this as
well yes um we we we're talking a lot
about principles but um uh Professor
ramchan mentioned legal boundaries and
that that's more our territory really
the law uh as part of a legislature and
um the question is uh to what extent do
you think that current legal
um uh Frameworks boundaries that exist
particularly of course international
human humanitarian law to what extent
there's enough there as it were to cover
these weapons however defined that we
still haven't got a definition of the
weapons which is a bit of a handicap
um uh do do we need new
new laws um well that's a question
um I mean obviously I realize that any
regulation would involve some
International agreements presumably but
at some point the the dear old
legislature would come into this and do
you think that um something new is
needed or not
may just hold your response to that that
that that's an important theme but I'd
just like to to move on to it in a
moment but I wanted to give Lord Brown
just a chance to come in I think you
wanted to come in on on on on the more
specific so yeah and I I I
meant it and specifically how we do
these things that we aspire to do
um
so
so we know that there has been no public
consultation in the United Kingdom of
our country's appetite for the
deployment of weapon systems that can
operate autonomously or
semi-autonomously we've been none
um
so but but we do have in a recent past
history examples of technological
advance in which we built a parallel
system of
um of studying the ethics of them and so
and but in our country and in the United
States I can't speak for other countries
but I suspect many most developed
countries certainly did this
is bioengineering improved
and is the concerns that we had about
its misuse or
um or effects developed we we built a
research
um a a a parallel research system that
wasn't quite funded as well as the
research into the bioenergy but looked
at the bioethics
so we had this constant parallel system
of bioethics in which there was this
constant conversation going on
and and for most of these countries this
conversation is developed into a
national regulator
you know and in the United States is
there a federal regulators and state
Regulators in the whole bioin
engineering field of comma of this
bioethic discussion I mean
I mean the g7r Prime Minister announced
that he was going to lead a global
regulation of AI and yesterday he
started it and he met with three people
who are key figures in the AI industry
in the United Kingdom for a couple of
hours so the job's done right so
um I mean I mean should we not do this
you know these complicated conversations
that we're having week after week after
week with people who are drawing out
these things that we're learning a
vocabulary for as we go along but have
responsibility for the public policy
should we not just take
from the bioengineering example and
establish a AI ethics frame of research
that we put sufficient money in to start
to test these things
Professor Remington I I completely agree
and I was that was actually my main
recommendation to this to this to this
committees is to actually find the body
that would have
um this authority to have these
conversations to to bring in the key
stakeholders
um and bring um and work alongside the
ministry of Defense to to to to to uh
advise on on and and and inform the
public and their stakeholders about what
what the implications of these systems
are uh currently the conversation is
owned by the media
uh and there's a lot of scare mongering
going around
um and this is led by uh people who are
not experts in the field or people who
are who have formed opinions about
autonomous weapon systems based on
writing a book I think you need to have
a wider conversation because it is not
just about the
um the technical elements of these
systems but the values that we hold the
ethics that we have in our society and
this varies across different publics so
we can't just decide this across you
know what autonomous systems we would
allow how we would allow the deployment
of these systems just you know with a
small group of people and I think going
to
um the tech industry and and and and the
Silicon Valley Titans as we call them
for for any opinion is is clearly not
the right way to go I think there will
be there's already been quite a few
investments in in the UK to look at
responsible Ai and trustworthy
autonomous systems and we are part of
these of these initiatives and we are
looking to to grow some of these uh
groups that bring researchers from
different disciplines to address these
key issues but I think something
specific focused on defense and
autonomous weapon systems is urgently
needed to avoid conversation being taken
over by the media and non-experts
interview
thank you Professor Dr diglin do you
agree as well yes I I totally agree
because also AI is developing uh
constantly and we recently have this
next Generation AI with a big language
models and um and generative AI so I
would also if I don't only focus on
kinetic weapon systems because cognitive
Warfare is also a weapon systems and
this new generation of AI turns out to
be very good to be a means to to try to
influence the public opinion Etc and we
should also take a broad scope
thank you Professor Kilda yeah thanks I
think it's difficult to have meaningful
conversations if they're too abstract
for me I would be focusing on the
actuation remember these are cyber
physical systems the physical actions
for example like weapons firing if we
can look at the classification of those
as I said AI in an air conditioning
system in doesn't particularly bother me
weapons firing does bother me and I
think we have to make sure the
conversations include those actuation
events otherwise it just feels a bit
navel gazing thank you very much let us
now move on to Lord uh growth's question
about uh international law international
humanitarian law the translation of of
our ethics into into operational
principles and then the holding of Us
and other nations to account
um who would like to come in on this to
begin with are our legalities sufficient
thus far and then Lord Mitchell will um
will sharpen the question up a little
bit in a moment
if I can win yeah
thank you um I I think right now there
are no laws and it's a huge debate in in
the legal committee around uh whether we
should allow systems or not and and a
web autonomous weapon systems and and
the question is whether you know we get
again everyone to agree when they all
hold different sorts of ethics and
values
um for example in Japan people tend to
have very close relationships with
machines they see them as as equivalent
to humans in some in some cases right
they have that companion take all the
old machines as companions in in other
countries the UK's adversaries they
might have different views on on on what
machines are allowed to do to humans
um and therefore not want to restrict uh
the use of these machines during Warfare
so it is a difficult challenge to try
and get everyone to agree on a set of
rules uh around restricting the use of
autonomous systems in in specific
War settings
so I think we we are going to struggle
to get that agreement and we need to be
mindful of the capabilities that others
are developing and come come up with
meaningful solutions that are that that
resonate with our publics in the UK
can I just uh yeah we understand that
you know there are lots of different
views about this but could I ask you to
if you like for your expert guidance as
to whether you you think
new rules is yet not quite defined
because of the difficulties you describe
but do we do we need them or not
the the difficulty there is that if you
impose rules you need to be able to
police them and AI is no different to
any other software
and if you're going to say only certain
a certain people allowed to build
software then that's not going to be
you're not going to be able to police it
so I think it's going to be it's it's um
it's difficult to impose those rules
um and in in particular I think it's
difficult to impose the rules when
um the adversaries are going to use
these weapons in ways that you don't you
can't control
um I think it's the same thing with
nuclear weapons and you can come up to
an agreement on on how and when
um people should be able to use them at
Warfare but anyone can build an AI
weapon potentially these days and that's
difficult to to to to regulate
Lord Mitchell I think it'd be helpful if
you were to come in with your question
now thank you Lord chair and it does
lead on from what um Lord grocott was
saying
um what international standards of
practice on development testing and use
of AI enabled and autonomous autonomous
weapon systems are needed if any
and I have to say I mean when I sit on
this committee and I listen to these
very profound questions that we're
asking that have major implications I
just sort of wonder whether the same
questions are being asked in Moscow
Beijing because this is an issue I I
guess like
nuclear issues which it takes two to
tango and we can't come to any
agreements unless the same things are
being done elsewhere and I have no feel
for it so Professor Corder if you could
kick off please thanks I would say are
we asking the question are they being
asked in other countries I could only
assume yes but also are they being asked
in other sectors so to my mind this
isn't just about regulation of AI as a
technology it's about its use we have to
ask the same questions in medical
devices in driverless cars yeah are you
going to buy a driverless car from
Moscow are you going to buy a medical
device from China we we're facing these
same issues across many sectors
and the question of regulation of course
is quite hard in the software sector
because we don't have these physical
residues yeah you don't unlike nuclear
weapons or chemical weapons it's hard to
find the traces so I think we have to go
back to the culture and the people who
develop the software and and a lot of
Arts about higher education and
education and but the people who are
participating in in those activities but
I think this is this is these are
international and cross-sector questions
you think
do you want to continue that I know that
that Lord
um Hamilton would like to come in in a
moment but let's continue with your
questioning if you'd like to no I'd just
like to hear what the others would like
to say lordiglam what um Mr diggle and
what would you like to say on this
yeah so I think that regulation can
definitely be effective uh in in we we
have the AI act developed by the
European Union uh which is I think very
important to have things like that in
place and we should be aware that it
should develop and cope up with a new
source of AI for example with a
generative AI there should be maybe
regulations like that the human has the
right to know whether he or she is
talking to a machine or a human and
these are very concrete enforceable
rules in the military domain uh we
should see which kind of these rules are
feasible and and are are useful to uh to
translate to the military domain but I
definitely think there's a role of a
legislation there
well-defined standards for ai-based
systems in in autonomous weapons
development so I think there are there
is an urgent need to build those sort of
testing Frameworks standards that would
help the defense industry build these
weapons in a responsible way and deploy
them responsibly
um and I think the research Community
has responded to that need in some ways
so there is there are initiatives in the
AI community that look to educate
researchers or or
um use the The Voice they have in in
various sectors to to to raise those
issues with decision makers
um that said most of the research in AI
is potentially funded by defense
and uh there is always this conflict of
you know doing research with the with
the defense uh companies that look to
use tools that don't look like uh they
will be using autonomous weapons but
habitual purpose so so it's a it's a
tricky thing to to to to to to control
and but I think developing standards and
and principles and education is key I
think too ensuring that these weapons
are built responsibly that deployed
responsibly and also regulated
responsible
Lord Hamilton did you want to come in
yes please I would very much just start
to return to the whole question of
international humanitarian law I think
you've indicated that it would be very
difficult to get any agreement to expand
the spectrum of international
humanitarian law not least because the
Russians refused to even entertain the
idea of signing up to any of this and
won't even talk about it
um surely there's a reverse side of the
same coin
um and that is that the existing
signatories to humanitarian
International humanitarian law have done
so because it's largely meaningless
by which I mean that the only charge it
seems anybody can stand up on this law
is war crimes and as they know that the
chances of ever proving or having
anybody guilty of war crimes is
absolute to the very small percentage
that's where they're prepared to sign up
to because they know that nothing will
ever happen under IHL
who would like to come in on this
briefly if we may because we're running
out of time
I'm not a local expert but I'd refer to
my to my expert colleagues on my on my
team but I think when it comes to
proving you know who's at fault I think
that's where the AI based systems can
potentially be
equipped with Data Tracking provenance
tracking
um toolkits that would help us prove you
know guilt in in situations where war
crimes might be committed I think
establishing standards around that may
help a bit with with
um with uh
with the enforcement of these the
enforcement of these laws but I would I
would differ to my my expert um law
colleagues to to to to to to provide a
view on this Dr diggling are you a bit
more optimistic than Lord Hamilton
well I I think that an important result
of this effort and and these discussions
that we are having is also to become
more aware of uh unforeseen risks of
this technology because we just will
don't know very well how this will play
out if we deploy AI in in all sorts of
domains and to become aware of that I
think that's in the benefit of every
country and that will definitely benefit
Humanity
I know Lord Brown would like to come in
very quickly but could we keep it very
brief it's just that you know I mean we
I mean this is a global challenge right
we can't insulate ourselves from this
you know I mean when I was a secretary
of state for defense I mean people were
telling me that you know in five years
time and they were right that you know
soldiers would go to work with iPads
right
I mean so it's not very well for us to
you know sort of
talk about what others are not doing I
mean at least what we can do in this
Parliament is is to say what we should
be doing but we've also got the Bear in
mind I mean I don't have my iPad with me
but I have my iPhone with me you know
and if you want to see justo
internationally it connected we are look
at the back of your iPhone
it says um designed in California and
assembled in China
so yeah I don't know whether the bits
were manufactured but it was assembled
in China and I guarantee you it says the
same in the back of an iPad so we're
giving our soldiers this we're giving
them something that changes have
assembled you know and we're not likely
to get anybody else to assemble them
because we can do it cheaper later than
anywhere else
and so we're interconnected you know and
we have to realize the degree through
which we are interconnected and work in
this and we should take people like Eric
Schmidt seriously when they say you know
AI not just in autonomous weapons or in
weapon systems or in driverless cars but
they just say it it exposes potentially
an existential risk to the human race
so we need to these may be uncomfortable
in worrying things for us and difficult
but our heads and they do but we need to
engage with
and we should learn from how we've done
it with other Technologies I think
bearing that point in mind uh I I'd like
to draw to a close with uh with a
question we've been putting to all
Witnesses
um and I think uh Lord Fairfax you're
going to put that question and perhaps
as I say if you do want to respond uh in
your answer to Lord Brown uh Lord
Brown's point please feel free to do
that
um if each of you could make one
recommendation to the UK government in
this area what would it be
thank you thank you that's a cooler
thank you mine will be a conjunction
that means it's one thing and another
the first is
we need consensus about human agency
in these systems and then we design
capability around supporting that so
it's not about the technology per se
it's about designing to some human
agency to support some human Agency for
example weapons firing and the second is
don't underestimate the power of the
international science community and I
think it's extremely important that we
stay connected
and the last thing is there's a bit of
hype at the moment
I don't think we've just fallen off a
cliff Edge this is just a Continuum of
software development and automation
thank you thank you professor ramton
I'll go back to my initial point which
is I think we need to set up a council
that would look at bringing different
stakeholders to have these conversations
around meaningful human control and all
these issues that we just talked about
try and Achieve consensus but I don't
think we we can we can we will always
achieve our consensus in some cases and
I think the the point about
um uh getting
um uh away from from the hype
trying to take away that that narrative
from from from the media and I think as
Professor I don't see AI as opposing an
existential risk I think climate change
is is probably more more likely to to
have to cause that risk
um so I think we need to to to now take
charge of that conversation and
acknowledge it is a sensitive issue and
the public should be involved in there I
think as this is philosophers engineers
and computer scientists and lawmakers
all great people to to involve in that
Constitution but at the end of the day
the public will have to to put our
politicians in in Parliament and and and
will decide on who's most effective at
defending the nation
um so engaging uh a national
conversation and engaging the public in
that National conversation would be my
advice to the government thank you very
much Dr digilen
yeah so um my advice would be to to look
broader than the weapon systems and look
at all ways in which AI will be deployed
in the military and that will likely be
part of the systems of systems or many
interacting components communicate and
maybe the AI will be used as a decision
support system upon which humans will
base their further decisions and
eventually this could very well lead to
the use of of weapons but then it's a
little bit more disguised than a
discussion around uh autonomous weapon
systems and
um well AI as an information processing
entity is is a very common application
and I think we will see the first
applications of AI in defense like that
and that is also uh we can lose control
over these systems as well
we're very very grateful for your time
for the talk yeah put into this session
and it's been hugely
um stimulating and you've helped us with
our thinking